riot has officially announced the new
season of competitive valorent and they
are not messing around we have been
talking four months about the huge
changes that will shape valor forever
and now we finally have some details
let's talk about it
hey everyone this video is brought to
you by your friends over at elgato as
you guys can tell i just moved and
honestly the easiest part of moving was
setting up all of my elgato products
like the mic arm the lights the mic so a
huge thank you and shout out to them if
you've been watching the channel for a
while you know i've been making lots of
videos regarding the future of valorant
specifically competitive professional
valor and what riot has planned for
future vct events back in april riot
announced changes that would be
occurring within the valerian
competitive scene in riot's valerant
partnership announcement they said for
2023 we will select partner teams across
our three international leagues who have
a track record of building great esports
experiences developing players and can
meaningfully contribute to the long-term
growth of valor and esports to make sure
we attract the best teams in the world
we will forego any participation
franchising fees and instead provide
financial stipends to the selected teams
in return for their investment in
growing the ecosystem we knew these
partner teams would be competing in
their own leagues we really didn't know
what these leagues would look like until
now in their press release ryan showed a
pretty little graphic demonstrating what
the competitive year will look like now
riot put out a whole load of information
so we have broken it down to make it a
little more digestible let's take a look
at what a typical year would look like
for valerian fans the season will start
off with two international splits these
will be played on land in three cities
for each of their respective
international regions los angeles for
the americas berlin for emea and seoul
for the pacific the first split will
usually start in february but be
replaced only in 2023 with a kickoff
tournament which we'll get to later the
second split will then begin around
march or april and both will last for
eight weeks these splits will be the
bread and butter regular games similar
to the splits that league of legends has
currently then in may we'll have masters
in much the same form we're used to the
top teams from each of three regions
will compete for a title and limited
spots to qualify directly for champions
around june and july we'll see the start
of the last chance qualifiers which many
of you are familiar with as the final
opportunity for teams to snag a single
spot at champions and then champions the
pinnacle of valerian's calendar will run
from august to september everything
we've just covered will apply to the
international league and their partner
teams what about teams that aren't
partnered well that's where the
challengers league comes in this will
run concurrently and also have two
regular splits one will begin in january
and the other in march culminating in
june's ascension tournament the
ascension tournament will happen the
same time as the last chance qualifiers
will give the best non-partner teams a
chance to move up into the international
leagues okay so remember i mentioned
that one off tournament for the
international league well it's gonna
take place of the first international
split but only for 2023 the winner of
this tournament will also get an extra
slot at masters for their region it will
be held in sao paulo brazil and ryde
said it will be the largest tournament
in vct history running for three weeks
from february to early march so this is
all a lot of new fun stuff a lot of
valorant fans are wondering how this
will all go down are these changes good
for valorant with valorant having
partner teams applying and then being
accepted into these spots some people
including myself were a bit worried that
these teams would just sort of coast and
not work on improving themselves if that
sounds weird think about it this way you
know in college in the states when
seniors apply to college early decision
and they get in and they just kind of
coast and do nothing for the rest of the
school year kind of like that like they
don't worry about the rest of their
grades they're in in valor's case if
teams can't be relegated they don't
worry about being kicked from the
program they can do the bare minimum and
coast is this a likely reality well
valerian fans we have a case study not
too far from here bride's other major
game league of legends have had a
partner system like valen's proposed one
since 2017. but as sean westlar
graciously explains based on league of
legends that is not most likely going to
be the outcome anybody who's running an
esports org cares about winning
obviously um so teams are incentivized
to continue to try to win because they
need to bring in sponsorship money they
want to make sure they have fans all of
these things are tied to an
organization's financial well-being um
so winning still matters of course
even if there's not this immediate
threat of your team literally being
ripped out of the league something i had
feared once the changes were announced
was the financial aspect of the vct
there are stipends aka money being given
to teams rather than them having to
worry about buy-ins which means teams do
not have to pay for their spot well that
could help organizations with the
financial burden of running a team isn't
all as cut and dry as it may seem um so
the only cost of running an esports team
is not the franchise fees right you've
got player salaries you've got staff
in a lot of cases you've got training
facilities all of these things cost
money
and esports organizations are a fairly
new business in the grand term than the
grand scheme of the entertainment
industry so each of these teams needs to
find their own business model but if
valor and salaries get to the kind of
astronomical highs that we've seen in
more established games like league of
legends or cs go and you get to a point
where players are being paid
hundreds of thousands in some cases
millions of dollars a year in salary to
play on these teams um those teams need
a way to recoup that money and surely
some of that has to come through this
partnership with riot i think it's a
positive change overall that teams
aren't having to buy in i think that in
the scope of esports we've seen some
reported franchise fees that to me are
honestly a little bit ridiculous um so i
think this is the right move from riot
in terms of valor and esports but it
doesn't remove the financial burden of
operating an esports team it just
removes this one slice of of those
expenses my personal view on all this is
cautious optimism i am more hopeful for
the future of the esport now that there
is a somewhat i guess completely
finalized structure with the partner
teams and the challengers teams however
we still aren't super sure what that
tier two scene will look like in terms
of participants since more and more
teams are still leaving the esport i
know there is the challengers league in
the tournaments that we will finally
have the information about but can you
blame me for still being hesitant about
what tier 2 will look like i've
expressed my fears about how riot will
handle tier 2 before and i'm not the
type to throw out my hands in the air
and say well they must have fixed it i
also still have questions about how the
challengers ascension and partner
program will work together i reached out
to write for comment about the
possibility of relegation but at the
time of recording this they have not
gone back to me what i am excited about
are those inter-regional matches it will
be so cool to see n.a face off against
ledam with these international splits so
all i can do is wait and cross my
fingers but at last the final pieces of
the puzzle are coming together for the
future of valorant and soon we won't
even have to say the future it will be
the here and the now
[Music]
i finally got my d and d dice i bought
them i got them here i got my plate i
don't know if you can see it so it's
behind my chair i got my players
handbook i got my my dice bag i'm ready
gamers i got my vax and my percy funko
pops if you know you know i'm so excited
and it'll be good i'm i'm back baby
cleric wayne liz is back